مع بدايه العام الجديد الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا تعود الى الواجهه ضربات جويه
مكثفه شنتها روسيا على مناطق اوكرانيه عده
بواسطه 90 مسيره من طراز شاهد ايرانيه
الصنع في منطقه الفيف الواقعه غرب البلاد
دمرت الضربات الروسيه جامعه ومتحفا
يعتبران رمزا تاريخيا بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا هذا هو المبنى الذي قتل فيه
الجنرال رو شوفيت قائد جيش المتمردين
الاوكراني تم انشاء متحفه التذكاري هنا
وكان هدف الهجوم القصف الروسي المكثف ياتي
في اعقاب سلسله ضربات شنتها اوكرانيا على
بلده بلغورد الروسيه ادى الى مقتل اكثر من
20 شخصا سبقه قصف روسي لمدن اوكرانيه
الجمعه اوقع حوالي 40 قتيلا وخلال زياره
خصصها بوتين الى الجنود الجرحى في يوم راس
السنه الجديده قال الرئيس الروسي ان بلاده
ستواصل ضرب اهداف عسكريه مهمه في
اوكرانيا انهم يريدون تخويف وخلق نوع من
عدم الاستقرار في بلدنا من جهتنا سنضع
الضربات التي ذكرتها بدون شك ولن تمر
جريمه واحده ضد السكان المدنيين دون
عقاب الرئيس الروسي الذي اعلن عبر وسائل
اعلاميه استعداد بلاده لانهاء الصراع وفق
شروط روسيه اكد استعاده المبادره
الاستراتيجيه على الارض فيما تعهد الرئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي في خطاب
العام الجديد بانتصار بلاده التي وصفها
بانها اقوى مما سبق